the question before us today is why were
the mongols so effective how do they
manage to take an area starting around
here and over the course of 20 years
during the reign of genghis khan from
about 1206 to 1227 expand from this
little
part of siberia just south of lake
baikal all the way into central asia
this is what
the mongol empire looked like in 1206
and this is what it looked like in 1279
this here is genghis khan time and this
here is around the reign of kublai khan
so what what enables a spread of
territory on this scale in such a short
time
you know the mongols were not a
centralized state they weren't a
centralized empire they were a band of
traveling horsemen how did they end up
taking
this much land the story of the mongols
is a story of a non-state actor
overcoming state actors of a
decentralized power
becoming centralized eventually
so what i want to talk about in this
video is three reasons why the mongols
were so effective in beating
established empires and then we're going
to talk about some of those follow-on
effects so reason one why the mongols
were so effective was planning what we
might call logistics
when genghis khan let me pull up a
picture of good old genghis
when genghis was declared emperor or
great khan of the mongols in 1206 one of
the first things he did was reformat the
army he swept away tribal affiliations
and favoritism if you were good you got
to have a higher position if you were
bad you didn't
and this meant that ordinary people
within the mongol army felt that they
could have a measure of social mobility
if they performed especially well in the
army and this made them very committed
and very loyal
reason number two the mongols were
extremely adaptable
so we're talking about a group of
horsemen here right these are the
mongols
attacking a group of of chinese soldiers
what they were used to was mounted
combat against mounted opponents what
they weren't used to was attacking major
cities and holding them or even trying
to get major cities to break but what
the adaptability of the mongol army
meant was that as they conquered new
territories and as they fought and won
and lost in various regions of asia so
for example as they started conquering
the western gea here they learned
siegecraft and that's the art of
attacking walled cities and castles
it's a completely different style of
combat what it involves is sitting
outside of a city and waiting to starve
out the inhabitants and part of it
involves using these things called siege
engines so this here is a kind of
catapult you can see here the rocks the
mongols are waiting with their archers
here
the opponents have
have arrows as well but they're flinging
rocks into the city in order to
force a surrender and the mongols didn't
really have this technology or these
tactics when they began their military
campaigns but as they rolled through
central asia they picked it up and then
they continued to use those tactics as
they swept westward now the third reason
that the mongols were so effective is
because they were terrifying
even though they mastered siege warfare
in the beginning at least the mongols
were not prepared to
hold a city once they had conquered it
so there are stories especially from the
conquest of the western jia and the
northern song
and the khwarezmian empire over here
that tell of the mongols winning a
battle and then sweeping in and
murdering everyone just pulling plunder
from corpses
uh and just looting the entire city and
leaving nothing standing
because the mongols weren't especially
interested at least early in the we're
talking about the period of genghis
khan's life here so 1200s to 1220s they
weren't especially interested in
governing they wanted to hold territory
and get tribute and get money but they
weren't especially interested in
running an empire
it actually made more sense to them just
slaughter everybody and take their
things
now got to the point that this
reputation for fearsomeness got so
powerful
that some cities would just give up and
surrender the moment the mongols arrived
so those are those are the three main
reasons that comprise mongol
effectiveness against settled states
they were very good at planning
everybody rode in their armies they
could move very quickly the mongols were
extremely adaptable every time they lost
they learned something from the people
they lost too
and that meant that they picked up new
technologies like siege warfare
and they were absolutely terrifying
since initially the mongols didn't know
what they were going to do with a
conquered city besides looted they just
killed everybody and that reputation
really allowed them to conquer a lot of
land very quickly
and so we see out of the mongol conquest
there are many follow-on effects but one
of the chief ones is something called
the pox mongolic of the mongolian peace
and if that if that phrasing looks
familiar to you it's because it's
similar to the roman peace the pox
romana and the chinese peace the pak
pakisenica of the first century ce this
is this is 1100 years later but the same
principle applies what happened was with
all of this territory conquered under
one ruling power
it became safe to travel from one end of
the empire to the other and indeed this
is exactly what marco polo did when he
set off from venice
and made his way eventually to beijing
and that would have been around this
time
marco polo's book the marv the book of
the marvels of the world was published
in 1300. marco polo was this um venetian
trader and adventurer who who traveled
extensively throughout asia
so that's one result
of the mongol conquests
is this mongolian peace now i should say
that this mongolian peace came at a
terrible price we were talking about the
terror of the mongols that's a for real
thing they murdered millions of people
but what would come after
the mongol conquest as a result of this
piece would end up killing even more
people than the mongol conquests itself
so this this pacified region this
mongolian peace led to increased trade
throughout east asia and reconnecting it
to eurasia and the arab states
and that would result in the exchanges
of new ideas and new technologies and
new agricultural techniques
but as trade always does it also results
in the exchange of diseases
and so out of the mongol homeland in
fact comes this illness
called the black plague or bubonic
plague and because of the stability of
trade that had been established by the
mongol peace
it makes it so much easier for this
illness to sweep across asia and europe
killing even more people than even
genghis khan could have achieved during
his lifetime